this intersection of AI and crypto I
think is a very interesting one that
will take many years to play out this uh
this sort of broad-based question of how
do we rest control of the compute
platforms of the future away from you
know the three or four companies that
have them and and my great developer
usage to these decentralized platforms
is of great interest to me just as
someone who's a a veteran of the web 2
Wars over the history of intellectual
property like going back Millennia we
sold it the way the way a creat got
Monet monetized their content is they
created some physical product and sold
it a book a work of art a sculpture
something like that and someone got to
own it and then resell it later and so
they were like invested in the long-term
economic value of people's works with
nfts we are back to being able to own
intellectual
property all right guys bang bang I've
got David here with me um I thought a
great place to start is you showed me a
chart that blew my mind I've never seen
this chart before you may be the first
person
uh to to uh have it and it shows a
market rally every time that a major
crypto CEO is fired or leaves and so you
have Arthur Hayes you have Sam mman
freed and then you have CZ talk a little
bit as so one how did you get the chart
or why why did you go think about this
and then two what is this chart actually
telling us well I just think that the
place we are we're entering the post
cleansing Rich infrastructure period of
crypto we spent the last two and a half
three years
building an abundance of block space
very low cost low latency and high
capacity blockchains so we're sort of
ready for way more consumer usage than
we had uh pre uh pre bare market and
we've spent the last year and a half uh
being cleansed by regulatory authorities
and getting rid of a bunch of Bad actors
and so I think uh the market likes
cleansing is what this chart shows us uh
this I can't take credit for it was a
coin fund um analyst here Dimitri who
put this together for us um but it right
the market appreciates the the cleaning
up of bad or questionable actors maybe
you could argue the one major actor that
is still uncleansed here is tether um
and we we still have a bit of a cloud
over the market until we get some
clarity about their long-term durability
but we're we're the market likes it when
exchanges with
questionable um characteristics
are cleaned up and uh so I think it's
just a good sign for where we're going
now when you look at each one of these
um how much of that is like institutions
are literally waiting and they're like
hey there's an exchange that you know we
have questions about okay that exchange
is no longer going to be a major piece
of the infrastructure okay let's go and
deploy Now versus um I almost think of
it like headline momentum and you know
people just talking about crypto
everyone's like oh yeah I forgot about
that thing I've been thinking about AI
for the last two years uh now that I see
crypto in the headlines I should go buy
some of that and then it's kind of like
retail flow is actually driving some of
these price appreciation after CEO leaps
maybe but I'm going to throw your words
back at you that you said on TV the
other day markets are forward-looking
and so this Market is a smart Market
there's a you know a lot of crypto
buyers and sellers in the market we've
got high volatility yes but we have a
lot of volume and particularly around
Bitcoin and Market likes uh Market's
looking forward and saying we like
Bitcoin more when we have less risk
regulatory risk of Bad actors being you
know pulled out that's simple so we've
seen recently a number of hearings we've
seen uh tweets go out from politicians
frankly on both sides of the aisle right
I don't think it's uh kind of just one
or the other um and it almost feels like
there are two camps now there are some
politicians regulators and even Market
participants who are like you know
accelerate let's go build let's use this
technology this should be uh the home in
America there's another group of people
though who are you know I mean literally
uh just recently Elizabeth Warren and
Jamie Diamond had an exchange and Jamie
Diamond's like it's all you know
basically Bad actors and if I was the
government I would shut it down and I
think Elizabeth Warren's uh you know
visual look was like thanks Jamie like I
got my new you know sound bite so how do
you think about maybe the Talk versus
the action and where do you expect us to
go in 2024 when it comes to regulation
so let me take one quick step back we've
spent a decade in my opinion building
the most robust
decentralized High performing lowcost
reliable mechanism for Global digital
movement or movement of digital items
including payments the the most obvious
use case for it is payments but payments
is one of the most globally regulated
Industries and protected in the world
and the one where there's a whole bunch
of graft essentially I mean you know the
tax for making payments across uh you
know bits moving updating a ledger
across the world is way too high you you
shouldn't be paying the fees you're
paying for a wire Western Union even
credit card so we built a much better
Network than that this is just the first
and most obvious use case but because
it's such an overly regulated sector
it's taken at least a decade for us to
start to make some progress into that
and then this is the announcement you
heard this week right coinbase saying
hey take our wallet and copy and paste
usdc payment links right into you know
iMessage or Whatsapp this is a free
globally free uh now like zero cost way
to move money around the world in
seconds 24 hours a day s days a week
that's an incredible Innovation it also
is a market shrinking Innovation I love
Market shrinking Innovations because it
puts the hurt on incumbents who don't
want to chase a shrinking Market they
want to fight and protect what what is
the number one way that regulated
Industries fight um people coming on
them through non-market strategies reg
regulatory so no surprise to me that you
have resistance from the global heads of
banks saying this stuff's bad it's just
an easy sound bite to try to delay delay
delay meanwhile you know the JP Morgan
Onyx internal blockchain like they they
they crow about how many billions of
dollars of assets are are secured on
that chain so this is Jamie Diamond
probably talking his book more than
anything he's he's too smart for that um
but um it's not a surprise to me that
we've got you know incumbents fighting
back through regulation I do think it's
a very sad State of Affairs in the US
because of the SP SPF you know donating
to7 some politicians that people are
just like anti- crypto from that but but
that's just a temporary blip I'm a
long-term investor we've been spending a
lot of time in the UK and EU and the Far
East where there's just no talk of Gary
Gensler or Jamie Diamond or Elizabeth
Warren they're just building and
watching now one of the most interesting
data points for me has been watching
usdc and tether and for a while it
looked like usdc was going to overtake
tether in terms of market dominance for
stable coins that has now reversed and
we actually see almost a bifurcation
where tether is gaining dominance uh
usdc is falling off the reason why it's
so interesting to me is uh I've heard
kind of rumors Rumblings whatever you
want to call it of people who have gone
and visited non- us jurisdictions where
people will say oh we like the fact that
tether is outside of the US system I saw
uh recently um I think it is a qow from
uh Alliance uh Dow he said um actually
he talked to someone who was in one of
the African markets and they said no
everyone here thinks that usdc is the US
government coin right and so we like the
idea of not having the US government
coin with the other one and what really
I think pulls that is just like
regulation in the US most people look at
that as like that's a positive like
thumbs up green light we want regulation
is it actually a negative
internationally and maybe the more we
regulate in the US the more it'll push
adoption of non-regulated things
internationally well let's be clear we
actually don't have crypto regulation in
the US we have selective enforcement
with an unknown set of rules uh and so
it's it's almost like a lottery of what
you can get away with or not get away
with in the you just don't know so when
you have that much uncertainty the best
entrepreneurs just opt not to be a part
of that system and to go where there is
some clarity the UK entrepreneurs and EU
entrepreneurs will tell you no we don't
have full clarity here but what they
have is we're not going to get sued for
launching a token in the US you launch a
token you there's a high probability
that you're named in a lawsuit somewhere
even if you know every best lawyer in
the world is telling you it's non
security uh so so the first piece is
like entrepreneurs go build where they
have some running room and I don't think
there's Running Room in the US today I
think it's going to change I'm a
long-term Optimist but right now it's
just not hospitable the second part of
your question is like well what is that
doing to the reputation of us companies
and products on the global market and
it's hurting us and and you're right
usdc which I think we all look very
favorably upon in the US is named in a
way that if you don't really understand
that it's a truly independent company
um you've got uh you know it sounds like
a US coin for sure and and right now
you've got a US is telegraphing not just
to its own citizens but around the world
like we don't like crypto we don't want
crypto here like don't touch our crypto
so no surprise to me um but by the way
like all non us well let's talk about
telegram for a minute so here we have
this you know messaging service with I
think 800 million uh Mal uh mostly non-
us many of us in crypto use it in the US
but it's heavily used outside the US uh
for you know just general messaging it's
got you know a Nexus with um founders of
Russian origin because of uh their their
backgrounds um and so it's you know it's
it's got a little bit of an overhang
over it here in the US for that reason
but it has launched a blockchain a token
and now a wallet that is being built
into a really easy to use consumer app
you can't touch it in the US it's geof
fenced away from us here for all the
reasons we just talked about but it has
maybe some of the most consumer traction
of any blockchain outside out there
something like 3 million um wallets I
believe and about 900,000 actives um um
monthly active wallets this is these are
big numbers in crypto right now um so uh
just an example of innovation activity
and and what could become very quickly a
seamless payments platform allaha WeChat
which we get gets a lot of talk in the
US someone's going to build a super up
this actually is is a more interesting
candidate to build one and going to
happen outside the US now I want to talk
a little bit about the institutional
world because I think when we talk about
regulation we talk about market dynamics
even sometimes macroeconomics people are
very much focused on the market
participants people allocating Capital
people consuming that Capital to build
stuff um but the capital usually comes
from somewhere right it's usually these
big large institutions and so they pay
attention um and they can sometimes be
very loyal to a market uh you know bonds
as a great example or kind of fixed
income regardless what happens in that
market they're going to keep allocating
to it crypto's on the other end of the
spectrum and it's almost a little bit of
fair weather over the last couple of
years you all raised a seed fund I think
the original Target was like $125
million um you raised about 155 160
million um in that fund and so over
subscribed from institutional type
investors why are they excited what what
is it other than coin fund is the best
investor in the world and you guys have
great track record uh and David Pacman
is you know great venture capitalist
what what what is so exciting to them to
keep allocating to this industry this
episode is brought to you by cal.com
what do I have in common with Chad
Hurley from YouTube Toby from Shopify
and Alexis from 776 and the co-founder
of Reddit we all use cal.com instead of
cly and we are all early investors as
well cal.com is leading the charge of
scheduling platforms and the open source
sphere offering you the chance to
harness the efficiency previously
reserved for elite corporations and Tech
gurus if you like to have your calendar
organized and be able to have an
efficient exchange when scheduling but
you love all of the benefit of Open
Source technology than cal.com for you
they are transforming sophisticated
calendar management into an accessible
tool for all via a user-friendly
interface you can customize it and you
can make your calendar work for you use
code pomp for $500 off when you set up
your team with cal.com today again go to
cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open
source tool that allows you to Take Back
Control of your calendar be efficient
when scheduling and make sure that no
one can steal your time I think there
are different there allocators that
allocate in different um sectors of the
market in general and different types of
asset classes so you know Venture is
this tiny pimple of a sector within
Alternatives but the people who invest
in Venture and who've been doing it for
some time the LPS the institutions who
invest in Venture they know it is a very
long-term slow liquidity bet it's a six
to 10 year fund cycle and a fund today
is not going to show its success for at
least six or or eight years maybe even a
decade or more so they are those types
of investors are like hey if there's a
bunch of noise in the market right now
that's not what I'm thinking about is
this an interesting sector over a decade
do I want to be in it really hard to say
that crypto is not if you're like like
just being an an objective investor
there's just too much activity too much
Innovation too much value created I mean
what what are we at today with the price
movement o over a trillion dollars of of
total asset value here you just can't
ignore it you kind of do it your own
Peril so to put some money into who who
would you put it into you would put it
into investors with a track record coin
fund's been doing it since 2015 uh in
investors who are institutional friendly
like we're registered with the SEC as an
RA and uh and trying to attract um
institutional Capital uh and people that
have thesis about where it's going and
try to avoid the Bad actors that seems
to me um to be a a smart move with
people that have a long-term investment
orientation but the other point that's
just about to change in the market is
you tell me the date but sometime in
January we're going to have probably 15
companies launching ETFs right to to
allow uh both retail and institutional
access to uh to crypto assets through
the stock market as ETFs and uh well I
mean that's a seminal moment right that
that is institutional adoption at scale
uh to at least Buy and Hold or or trade
digital assets I think that you know
this is the beginning of it all again Le
let's um let's take off kind of the
crypto hat for a second and just leave
the Venture Capital hat on um there's a
lot of Industry change that's happening
uh it feels like uh Mac economics
definitely driving some of that
valuation uh compression or multiple
compression has occurred um there was uh
some major blowups as there always is in
you know kind of the headlines and so
people get a little nervous what are the
trends that you think will remain the
same right like what are the things that
you're like hey look regardless of the
change if we just continue to do X as
Venture capitalists we'll make money uh
in 2024 and
Beyond well I I will say I'm an
evidence-based investor not a religious
one so I I don't declare that a market
is going to be the only place that you
should put your money because six years
from now crypto will change the world
I'm looking for evidence and so the
evidence I look for is where are
developers building what's the quality
of the developers and what's their
ambition level and even in this brutal
bare market for the last two years when
you attend the developer conferences and
you meet with the teams they still are
amazingly high quality I think I would
argue today pound-for-pound even higher
quality than any other time in the
market just because you got to be a True
Believer to have been building in the
last few years their ambition is to
build globally available products that
you know change mostly the financial
system but in some cases change
consumers um ownership of digital assets
like nfts in gaming um and their um and
their ability to attract talent and
Inspire leadership uh is is strong uh
it's not the only place you find that
intact you see it in a lot of Leading
Edge markets but um this is still true
today and I think I would argue that
it's we're we're we're past the trough
and we're emerging from a a challenging
build period with really rich
infrastructure we've got great working
layer ones we've got super fast layer
twos we have like 25% of layer to
settlement is already on zero knowledge
which is maybe one of the most
interesting um you know pieces of
infrastructure ever built across all of
Tech certainly hard to build zero
knowledge um and so we we're sort of
ready but at the same time like how many
users are using stuff on top of this and
this is where I'm very self-critical of
this ecosystem it's why I brought up the
telegram example where is there evidence
of adoption and that's the only way that
we will build Venture returns over a
decade we need consumers or Enterprises
to to be built using apps built on top
of blockchains and so what are the
candidates for that should I offer one
or two okay so love that one is Stables
right we've been talking about stable
coins already but I haven't checked the
last few days but my guess is 13040
billion dollars of uh of total stable
coin minted activity today this is not a
small number it's been higher in the
past but it is a beautiful product right
being able to send digital dollars or
digital Euros at effectively no fee like
unbelievably low fee certainly one 100th
of the cost of using other networks 24
hours a day seven days a week with no
middleman like no no trust required
that's an extraordinarily important
innovation it now needs to be uh
integrated into more and more products
but I think it will we have PayPal
announcing right that they've got 430
million monthly active users and 40% of
their users do crossb remittance and the
fees are too high doing crossb
remittance this is a public company and
they said what's our solution to high
fees for crossb remittance we're making
our own stable coin and we're sending
them PayPal to PayPal over public
blockchains that's an incredible example
let's watch the volumes I think Shopify
is a company to watch here they claim
their building a lot of web 3 products
that they're going to start to unveil
what would what's interesting to Shopify
in web 3 probably getting the fees on
payments down like if a user wants to
buy something from a Shopify Merchant
could you imagine if like you
automatically buy stable coin and then
that's automatically transferred into
the Merchant's wallet and the fees are
zero like there goes the 3.25 % on every
transaction and they're what percentage
of the total uh e-commerce market like
large so here is we evence Stables um
and then you know I think we we we look
for evidence of consumer usage uh of
gaming um uh nfts we saw obviously a lot
of activity that's that's come way down
but we had the Disney announcement that
they they're in this market now with
their most interesting IP um Amazon
coming to market with the nft offering
uh I I'm I'm sort of hedging a little
bit here because I want to see the data
um but but I I think that's also uh a
use case that we that we watch now when
we look at 2024 uh I always go to what
are the what are the narratives right
and you can go back there was you know
the defi Summers there was obviously um
Bitcoin and kind of nation state
adoption and and we can go through a
bunch of these different ones what are
the things that you're paying attention
to most like you're talking right now
about like usage uh sometimes those was
align with the narrative sometimes they
don't frankly and so what what are those
narratives that you're paying attention
to as we go into the new year crypto was
too hard to use for the last decade so a
lot of companies have spent a lot of
time kind of creating web to like
onboarding experiences more like
username and password then you know some
crazy 12 or 20 some word phrase right um
so making non-custodial wallets easier
to use and there are seven or eight
companies that have built a lot that
that are getting adoption like if you
look at their client list of who's on
board with them it's impressive so as
those products come to Market do we see
really we're just looking for like
consumer conversion rate like what's the
abandonment when youve come to a web
page and try something out um versus uh
web two and we got to get those numbers
way down um we've seen some examples of
that being of that you know being what
to like in its adoption so let's watch
that if if if that happens we we can
expect much more consumer usage this
wave so that's one we're watching
closely another is like what's the
durability of the apps one thing that a
lot of people got excited about this
year was frch um it you know sort of has
very Crypton native appeal to it like
betting on um B basically trading on the
value of uh of social celebrities and
social influencers um but uh but you
know its durability is in question here
and so we care not about the sort of
quick spikes in usage but are they
products that um can consumers will use
over time so um I think that's the theme
we build a lot of infrastructure who's
using it we're going to watch it closely
what can go wrong is like none of it
none of it
sticks now um you've been doing this a
long time and uh you've seen I would
think almost everything but I don't know
if anyone ever saw the open AI situation
before right that might be the one that
every single person I've talked to is
like I saw everything until that one um
what are your takeaways from that both
for Founders and maybe also for Venture
capitalists and and kind of people who
are investing in these you know very
explosive asymmetric type opportunities
in Venture Capital this episode is
brought to you by aradon they are a
brand new startup led by a number of
Silicon Valley Legends who just raised
$81 million to build the future of
Internet infrastructure you're probably
wondering what that means let me explain
there are numerous new disruptive
technologies that are being adopted
simultaneously from blockchain to
artificial intelligence to zero
knowledge Technologies in order to
ensure that these Tech Technologies
thrive in this new world we need new
infrastructure and that is where arine
comes in they just launched their first
product line called Tera flux which is a
Bitcoin miner powered by the world's
first 4 nanometer silicon chip
technology these aircooled singlephase
and dual phase emerging cooling miners
have unrivaled speed and efficiency
they've Superior uptime and they
leverage a brand new innovation called
Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
idine.com that's a a d ne.com go check
them out at ar.com today I'm so glad you
brought it up because what's not being
talked about around this is um you have
something like
10,000 companies that have built on top
of open ai's API and one of them even in
the information this week they detailed
like Morgan Stanley has built
significantly on top of open AI open
ai's API like somewhere in their
workflow I think it's in like their
private bank when like u a private
wealth manager is talking to a customer
there's like a you know a open AI chat
about that's helping them decide what to
talk about uh and they had emergency
meetings over the weekend because here
we have a company that's in the middle
of a tender offer at $80
billion that almost evaporated in 48
hours because of a Founder
dispute so like that is the opposite of
anti fragile right that is that is so
unbelievably fragile it's so web too
that you've got a platform company that
tens of thousands of companies have
built on that could literally 700 of the
770 employees are going to leave if um
you know we were within minutes of that
happening uh and that that to me is
every reason why I like web 3 because
what you don't have happened to ethereum
is like Joe Luben and and F falic have a
disagreement and so everyone who's built
on ethereum is suddenly in Jeopardy like
the network doesn't go down because of
those types of governance issues and we
as the users and by users I mean
developers have a say in the governance
of the software so we need platforms
that everyone's building on to be way
more durable to be
antifragile and you don't have them in
web 2 at all you're you're counting on
the largess of like people of failable
humans that are like number in the six
or seven or eight or 10 people so um
this was just a stark reminder for me
that we need just like we need
decentralized compute platforms we need
decentralized AI platform which is an
area that we've invested pretty heavily
in during this this bare Market um I
mean it was shocking shocking one of the
areas that um has been very hot outside
of crypto is artificial intelligence now
um artificial intelligence many people
who are experts there if you talk to
them they're like well if you got data
and then you can use this artificial
intelligence there's value that can get
created
seems like there's a lot of data on a
blockchain right there's a lot of uh
both transactions there's all kinds of
information do you see these two
industries kind of blurring the line and
actually coming together in some form or
is that maybe uh both Ai and crypto
people trying to like you know team up
just to get more hype around what are
already pretty hyped up Industries if
you didn't like investing in my company
when I was crypto How about if I'm AI
will you invest yeah for for sure
there's some of that at play but but I
also appreciate you bringing this up
because you know you you have a lot of
words on the internet that you've spoken
and written and I'm pretty sure that a
whole lot of that was scraped by the
training data sets in Google and open AI
have they sent you any shares in openai
or any compensation for any of that I'm
just curious no no it must have got lost
in the mail yeah right well you know
they they I'm sure they've read the coin
fund website and my blog post too and I
haven't gotten any shares either so here
we have like the biggest graft of um of
some a pillaging of content that that
creators have uh have have created over
the last decade and filled with the
internet and we have six or seven
companies who've scraped it all and
built tens of billions of dollars of
value without any compensation to any of
us and and this this will be settled in
the courts this is a copyright question
um I am on the uh I am on the the side
that having been through the music Wars
I I do not think this will be rendered
fair use especially if the chatbot like
which has already been proven like spits
out word for word what other people have
said I mean Fred Wilson's blog alone had
to teach the thing everything it needs
to know about Venture Capital the guy's
written more about Venture Capital over
a decade right he hasn't gotten paid I
asked him this question so uh why is web
3 relevant here because web3 has a model
where contributors whether you're
developers or content creators can get
rewarded in tokens uh when you put
things into a network into a data Supply
or we can do air drops even after the
fact we can look back we could we could
deploy an AI um model to train on
information on the blockchain we already
know the address of what put that data
on the blockchain we can do an airdrop
of tokens back to it if we've used it
this is a much more Equitable Model A
more democratic model where the users or
the contributors get some some share of
in the upside now the problem is there's
not an example of us doing this in web 3
right now around AI but but that's the
we've solved the problem before we even
knew we needed it what are the areas
that maybe people are excited about that
you're not not excited about in crypto
are there things that you know maybe
you're like ah it's hard for me to see
that becoming a thing but I understand
other people are either excited about or
or capital is Flowing there or or
developers are working on
it I I think uh this intersection of AI
and crypto I think is a very interesting
one that will take many years to play
out this uh this sort of broad-based
question of how do we rest control of
the compute platforms of the future away
from you know the three or four comp
companies that have them and and my
great developer usage to these um
decentralized platforms is of great
interest to me just as someone who's a a
veteran of the web 2 Wars um and and boy
I mean we saw over and over again the
Whimsical nature of what it's like to
build on a platform like Facebook or
Twitter where the CEO pulls the rug I
mean we should have invented the term
rug poles to to talk about the web two
platforms not the web 3s um so I I'm
really focused on like durable uh
decentralized platforms for a lot of
different use cases not just basic
blockchains but you know I'm interested
in in AI training models AI inference
models and and Jake Brookman our our CEO
has spent a lot of time publishing
thesis on this I'm also just really
interested in the ownership of uh
intellectual property and what that
really means to I mean you you're a
content creator you've got a model
that's um that that is perfectly
applicable to web 3 where you know you
could be
well let me just back up and say over
the history of intellectual property
like going back Millennia we sold it the
way the way a Creator got Monet
monetized their content is they created
some physical product and sold it a book
a work of art a sculpture something like
that and uh someone got to own it and
then resell it later and so they were
like invested in the long-term economic
value of people's works then we hit Web
Two where as we made content digital we
could not control its replication right
it's it's too abundant and so therefore
we had to go to access models if you
want to listen if you want to patronize
me you got to like pay for access to my
stuff and then when you stop paying I'm
going have shut that off Spotify Netflix
subscriptions but that's like this
bubble in time over the history of
intellectual property with nfds we are
back to being able to own intellectual
property which is historically the way
humans liked to um like to uh support
and and uh and enjoy intellectual
property so I am super bullish on this
idea that we're gonna enable ownership
of intellectual property again but it
has not you know fully played out and
and so even though nfts are way down
it's an area of great interest to me now
David you talked about the areas that
are of great interest um before we end
what is the promise of working with coin
fund right I think one of the pieces
that uh Founders especially first- time
Founders don't understand is there's a
lot of people with capital but you want
to work with people who actually can
help you build your business and so how
do you all think about that at coin fund
and and if somebody takes money from you
guys what is kind of that that promise
that you have to them uh in terms of why
you may be a better fit for them than
maybe over other Venture capitalists you
know I'm a former entrepreneur I've
started two companies and and and worked
at three startups and um it's hard the
odds are super against you you're
probably not going to succeed like I
mean that's what the data shows us right
they they say that venture capital is
the Triumph of Hope over data like it's
so is being a Founder like it's probably
not going to work out so how do you
increase your chances of success myo is
like surround yourself with people who
are smart and have experience to help
you avoid the problems help you see
around corners so we've built coin fund
to be more than our money we want to
help you build we want to help avoid
some mistakes we want to help accelerate
you through hiring connection strategy
Partnerships um and and we have a
network of now 105 companies we've
invested in since 2015 we've got a lot
of scars mistakes that were made um
crypto is also a different path than
traditional software companies because
of tokenization and now because of the
Nexus with regul regulatory bodies where
should you build which geographies
should you launch in uh what's the
should you launch a token and if so how
and why it's it's sort of a unique set
of questions that I think certain Crypt
native ECS um are uh are well suited to
and the last thing I'd say is that um
we've survived we've been through
multiple bare crypto markets and we're
stronger now than ever we raised more
capital in the last two years than We've
Ever Raised and we're being really
judicious and thoughtful about how to
invest it we've got institutions who
believe in us so we hope we're durable
but but but ultimately um ask our CEOs
are we helpful or not do we help them
accelerate that is uh that's the best
pitch just go talk to the people we work
with and they'll tell you what what they
think I hope so I mean we're not perfect
you know we make mistakes but but that's
the measure of whether we're good or not
where can people find you on the
internet if they like to talk about
anything that you talked about here
today yeah I'm still on that um that uh
platform of Hellfire called X um so I'm
Pacman p a m an uh but uh you can find
me there you find me everywhere I'm I me
it's fine David Pacman there are two of
us one is a younger uh um influencer who
does a lot of political talk that's not
me but uh I'm the only one no I'm not
the only Pac-Man in crypto you've got
Pac-Man from blur
who but no so I'm Pam and please come
find me awesome David thank you so much
for doing this uh I've been a big fan of
yours for a long time coin fund
obviously has a a strong track record
and and continues to uh be a great
Steward of the industry so cheers Tom
you are the man an incredible Community
Builder a sane voice a sage voice and a
Believer and it's great to have you as a
Guiding Light through crypto we'll do it
again soon my friend good to see you